[Musica]
alè
facciamo subito un selfone così
Eh vai fate del casino
fate una foto non serve a niente Ok 16
minuti vai ok Un marels Insomma sapete
già di cosa sto parlando io sono il
maggiore esperto mondiale di umarells e
sono venuto qua per
trasmettervi tutto il mio sapere
come è iniziato sto sto delirio qua
degli umarells perché questo Cioè tutti
dicono in Maremma come è iniziato tutto
è iniziato qui in questo posto io che
sono un umarell dentro nel senso che
sono molto puntuale arrivo sempre in
orario anzi in anticipo che una condanna
e mi trovavo qui in questo luogo che era
il parcheggio del cinema Star City di
Rastignano e stava aspettando un mio
cliente cliente un maree perché
appuntamento alle 9 Rastignano febbraio
Cioè non ha alcun senso E vabbè sono qui
inizia a scattare delle fotografie e a
che cosa Questo al cinema Star City di
Rastignano Voi dite Ma che foto sono
cioè sono delle fotografie che mi
servivano per il mio blog al che in
questa tundra desolata era anche molto
freddo passa un numerello tipologia un
Marel col cane
e mi vede che faccio queste foto alle 8
e mezzo di mattina mi dice Scusi lei
cosa sta facendo
e ho detto sto facendo delle fotografie
per chi preso merda Allora era un foto
per internet all'epoca internet era i
pedofili ti ruba la carta di credito
quindi ho detto una foto per il
giornalino della parrocchia e va bene va
bene ok Poi dopo arriva il cliente salgo
in macchina e io
dal bauletto del mio scooter prendo un
giornalino di quelli Free Press lo metto
dentro a un cestino del Rusco come si
dice qua a Bologna e andiamo via guardo
nello specchietto retrovisore e lumache
questa cosa mi ha talmente colpito che
al pomeriggio poi ho scattato anche
questa fotografia qua e
ho cominciato a dire a usare la parola
umarell e youmarell sono tanti Sono in
mezzo a noi Ci osservano e noi
osserviamo loro e io ho iniziato a
fotografarlo Ecco questo Umbria vi
faccio vedere un attimo
Ecco qua Questa è la foto originale qua
c'è il dettaglio ok e ho aperto un blog
e subito è diventato Popolare da subito
mi ha chiamato subito Radio 24 la RAI e
la Pina di Radio Deejay Gianluca
Nicoletti Radio 24 Insomma un delirio e
gli ombrello sono diventati
popolarissimi Infatti vedete qua ad
esempio sono Graffiti sugli umarell Cioè
anche gli ultras degli umarell questo è
una novità su Dylan Dog sul Topolino
addirittura questo è un folle che sei
tatuato una foto del mio libro Hans
Fabris
sobrio Sobrio e parole crociate
battezzaghi plurale anche la bolognese
degli osservatori di cantieri un Mares
Gramellini che parla le parolacce e
insomma dell'iniziativa
che può vedere l'operaio Insomma da più
vicino
poi ad esempio questa è una foto
scattata durante il lockdown si intitola
Smart working
ha chiuso in casa per la pandemia e si è
trovato questo bene Dio Questo è
un'opera che ho raccolto firme per
realizzare questo sogno e Piazzetta
degli umares qua l'abbiamo inaugurata
vedete cioè
esiste Cioè non è non è sono cose
proprio tutte vere e nel mondo ci sono
Insomma persone che parlano la mia
parola preferita è un Marel nel mondo
così e questo qua non so non so cosa
voglia dire però insomma vuol dire che
gli Human resoviti nel dizionario gli
humarello sul Times e Human reso Ma tu
da tutta sta cosa dell'umore 0 in quel
parcheggio arriviamo alla parola
lumachelli che entra nel vocabolario
Zingarelli
applauso che questa parola che è entrata
nel dizionario perché
questi cacciatori di parole avevano
visto che la parola umarell figurava
dappertutto i giornali ne parlavano su
tipo 150 libri c'è la parola allora
hanno deciso di mettere questa parola
che è un po' con le parole tipo petaloso
no che fanno
piacciono molto Ecco questa foto così
ecco io ci tengo sempre a dire che io
non ho inventato di un Marelli un
Marelli sono sempre esistiti cioè io mi
immagino anche non so Eh la costruzione
delle piramidi d'Egitto sugli umarell
che stanno guardando lì questi invece è
una foto molto importante che parla di
un Marel che sono i Beatles nella
copertina di Abby Road e disco uscito
ehm il 26 settembre Quindi preparatevi
che tra due giorni celebreranno questo
qui Questo disco perché ecco vedete in
questo tondo se allungare cioè magari
quella cosa fantastica peloni qua così
che ogni anno intervista lumarell che
quindi tra qualche giorno Ricordatevi
questo questi invece sono un Marelli in
via San Donato Va beh insomma la cosa un
po' vi tolsiani la Pro Lu Marelli il
dizionario si trova tra la parola
umanoide E umato che vuol dire sepolto
quindi cioè è proprio un percorso
e c'è scritto questo c'è scritto questo
con il plurale
fondamentale con la s finale umarells
[Applauso]
cosa succede succede che io c'ho i
cultori del dialetto bolognese che sono
incazzatissimi con questa S tipo Marco
chiesa che ha scritto questa lettera al
quotidiano satirico Il Resto del Carlino
e dice Ho letto in un articolo del
Carlino il termine umarels inteso come
plurale di un Marel Ma se non sbaglio il
plurale dovrebbe essere un è vero è vero
però ormai purtroppo è successo questo è
Quindi Marco Chiesa Ciao
Andiamo avanti con stile di vita o
magari si nasce non si diventa
a Bologna youmarells ai quali è stato
dedicato una piazza sono i pensionati
che fanno cosa siedono al bar guardano i
lavori stradali giocano a bocce ballano
liscio chiede Fabio Insinna e la
risposta giusta vedete che il
concorrente un marello anche la risposta
giusta è la b Però in realtà Va bene
tutte perché gli umarell c'è un Marel
fanno tutte queste cose Un magari di
varietà Abbiamo qua un mare nel qua un
gruppo variegato un carrellino
qua c'è il tocco femminile
dell'ombrellino
che non ha lo skill delle mani dietro la
schiena però insomma
E qua Insomma abbiamo un po'
la postura studio della postura vado un
po' veloce perché voglio darvi più
informazioni
esistono tre macro posture la prima
questa mani intrecciate dietro la
seconda ti stringi il polso la terza il
dito un dito a caso cioè Scegliete voi
il dito poi c'è la quarta che è La 1 la
2 o la 3 con oggetto tipo le chiavi
variazioni a tema Questo non l'ho
studiata però l'ho beccato la monomano
la monomano questa mano mano
utilizzata dalle stauree che tengono a
braccetto Lu marell e intanto tengo la
mano mano
parentesi sulle stauree tutti amazontti
sei sessista non tratti lisdaure Eccole
qua le loro splendore di Zare
snaughe che gli piacciono i cantieri
perché io non scrivo un libro
completamente sulle zone Perché io ho
paura delle SDA ore
e questo
Questo è il perché c'è musica alta
anziana picchia un gruppo Punk cioè cioè
non il cantante non che ci sono i
maneskin E picchi a Damiano No cioè
tutti tutti Allora
lasciamo perdere che si incazzano invece
non ho problemi che sono contenti Anzi
la passione per i cantieri
allora
Allora se questa passione e gli operai
si proteggono con queste barriere e
l'umarell si guarda e vedete fa ridateci
il cantiere quel telo si oscura lo
spettacolo
a Rapallo trovano questa situazione
questa soluzione degli i sindaci però
sono importanti lo schermo
qua si mettono insomma anche per il cane
la fessurina il bambino
qua insomma
Addirittura C'è uno fa questa visione a
Come si chiama volo d'uccello e poi si
creano Insomma delle Sinergie quindi
questo
la direzione di si sia spostati
seguiteci
prima si parlava di calo di nascite qua
di Carlo di umarel qua sono sono graditi
gli umarell Quindi qua cerchiamo degli
umarell altra cosa ci sono questi
cartelli con le tariffe per gli umarell
e questo è una foto ma vedete qua sono
varie foto cioè dappertutto metto le
tariffe per per gli umarell lascia Lo
Sfizio lo trovi in un cantiere Ecco
questo è passione vera passione vera
folla passione passione
l'umarell si avvicina e così troppo
curioso Magari cade nello scout
andiamo oltre il cantiere Ecco andiamo
in questa parte che la più interessante
l'abbiamo per adesso avete imparato le
posture il cantiere lo sapevamo le
tecniche di controllo
del territorio gli Ungarelli gli piace
controllare il territorio non nemico che
inizia per p e finisce per pubblicità e
si difendono con queste cartelle Allora
i più estremi mettono dei cartelli come
questo vietato l'ingresso di stare al
condominio Insomma è proprio
estremissimo metto questi cartelli
pubblicità questo per l'Esselunga
l'Ipercoop Leclerc varie così però sono
eludibili vedete no pubblicità tu gliela
metti eh eh
Non suonare per la pubblicità
non suonare però se suoni da falichieri
da cernacchi Cioè e poi puoi dargli la
pubblicità e poi sono i casi estremi
tipo questo che c'è chi la vuole tipo
Riccardi no
non è gradita la pubblicità escluso
Riccardi
qua se Fabbri che la vuole dice chiamare
a voce Fabbri
postino Ti devo parlare Sono al
campanello
campanello per aprire il gatto rosso
Ecco questo è molto bello
qua andiamo insomma la zanzara tigre il
si prende il mettere in moto i motorini
che danneggiano viene salute
l'ascensore ascensore al tuo posto
critico
di età qua un consiglio perché di
Ungaretti consigliano oltre a vietare
Allora chiudere le porte scese in modo
normale
e qua invece bisogna aspettare che
l'ascensore
Questo è un ascensore particolare
che il numero dei tasti non corrisponde
spesso nelle piante dove vanno dal
secondo ma il quarto va bene
e un problema
i peti in ascensore ripeto un grosso
problema
Non scoreggiare in ascensore sappiamo
chi sei ne parliamo con l'amministratore
e qua si rivela dopo la lettera
dell'amministratore non mi prenderete
mai firmato lo scoreggione
questi sono cartelli forum dove
praticamente c'è Tu puoi rispondere
se ti becco te la faccio mangiare la
cacca del tuo cane bau Vergognati
Questa mi piace molto perché ci siamo
trasferiti di fronte non è vero di
fronte c'è il negozio di intimo Hai
ragione diciamo allora la strada Va bene
ma più precisione la prossima volta
condomini infernali vietato qui vietato
il pallone vietato giocare a pallone con
i piedi
vietato pattinaggio a rotelle vietato
Allora mi drogo ecco
questo sono delle tecniche tecniche che
poi illustrato in tutti i miei libri Qua
c'è quando l'umarelle esasperato mette
dei cartelli a norma di legge
ad esempio questo dice articolo 158 così
al massimo alla cassa cioè
Sosta Vietata in motocicli tipo questo
attenzione piove pipì di cane dal
balcone al terzo piano ed è l'articolo
674 del Codice Penale
e come vedete se non si desidera
ricevere la pubblicità e del 6 e 14
è vietato introdurre materiali
pubblicitario 633
è vietato
663 quindi Fateci caso poi c'è il
classico che è il
675/96
evitate naturalmente pubblicità nelle
cassette postali e questo lo potete
osservare si trova in via Mascarella
proprietà privata vietato l'accesso ai
non autorizzati i trasgressori saranno
perseguitati
a norma di legge bene Io ho finito
Ciao a tutti
Trionfo
Viva gli umarells e
lesnagore Ma attenti Ecco ciao
[Applauso]